[Applaudissements]
ensuite c'est le peloton on l'envoie
proclamation moi j'avais signé hier et
on ne rajoute pas mais trois points ça
va pas du tout quels traits way tel
derby mais j'y vais mais j'y vais bengy
verra je te dis que personne mais là
mais tu me moi tue moi parce que je joue
ici si je pars tu vois plus tu que janot
qui se voit ça un chien ou un chat non
le nouveau technicienne du plateau là ça
va sûrement par l'eba je suis content
d'être ici et ben ouais ouais ouais je
m'en occupe de s'en excuser moi il faut
que je m'occupe des micros prendre le
problème au pot la caisse c'est ce petit
cul de tennisman là et c'est du boulot
de compétition ça allait lever le même
pc bionis et de tunis est pas alors
qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'on en
direct bah oui c'est le principe ça veut
dire c'est à dire si je dis un truc là
il ya tout le mexique qui mentent en
prépa le coupé quoi exactement moi c'est
le direct bon ben je vous le dis alors
je vous adore monsieur demain s'ouvre
déchiquetant au nom super content de
jouer comme ça il ya les cinémas pathé
gaumont qu'un de téléphoner pour amener
le fauteuil
oui ça va ma merde
vous pouvez y aller non alors maintenant
je suis allé je suis pas parti jacques
tène la mauvaise nouvelle ce qu est ce
que je peux est ce que je peux vous je
vous le dirai que je vous adore mois
déjà mais quand vous faites le chose
comme ça c'est de la truite là je me
régale et ça rime s'est jamais si le
truc petit bras la craie est-ce que je
peux être beaujoire mont-édouard le
suisse avait même baissé que je boive à
ses pieds on peut profiter
thierry moreau
ces messieurs vont vous êtes un génie
vaud valais c'est vraiment de la merde
[ __ ] je me disais un truc pour vous un
point kono mise un peu les choses
pourquoi vous acier pas directement dans
le public vous attendez quand vous avez
une bonne vanne on vous dit tu lui
rentre plus à oui ça va t'aider à part
nommé monsieur monsieur jean miche
meriem problème toi là il est mûr à ce
que je me disais ouais ouais donc qu'il
en parle beaucoup mais bon ils viennent
pas toujours avec ja reviennent pas je
pensais pas qu'un jour je serai ici
comme là là là là mais je me serais vous
je joue je vous attends h vous le dirai
que normal si vous avez besoin de
quelque chose jadot pouvais me demander
n'importe quoi
vous l'aurez pas me vouent leur est
demandé avant tout les artistes que vous
avez lancé il paraît qu'à l'époque vous
avez lancé mimie mathy alors que c'est
interdit
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ce qu'il n'y a pas de petits réglages à
faire sur le micro des droits non parce
que je suis devant son micro
non ok mais y en a deux des droits ce
soir et à force bleus fort ce rouge et
noir amandinois je voulais dire jouer
moi je suis fan de vous je vous trouve
belle comme tout et vous êtes pour moi
vous êtes le parfait mélange entre
charlize theron et joey starr et oui non
mais ça ça bouge pas normalement ça
c'est sais c'est que je suis pas un
hasard a été testé en soufflerie ça
résiste à mcdo mc3 normalement je
vérifie pour faire plaisir aux gens
normal ça bouge pas franchir la tâche je
vérifier moi dans ma b nadine bennani
c'est ça quand on a pris un coup de
soleil sont même pas de but at il
analysé
mais parfois je n'ai pas de la ciotat
non non parce que j'ai un copain qui
s'appelle un patch qui tamponne une
valérie
[Rires]
s'attend à ne s'attend pas notre
contrôle et ça tombe pas de cet enfant
ne m avait pas la poste des conneries ça
te plairait père et se régale à la hâte
et j'ai appelé mon copain loool parce
qu'il connaît tous nolan tools tous les
dossiers de la ciotat icaunais loool
ces jaloux je suis je suis à touche pas
à mon poste a essayé et je travaille
touche pas à mon poste tout mais si le
pakistanais les simpson je suis mes
mails 1,8
mais la vie te regarde regarde regarde
si je suis rien acquis des luttes à dire
que jamais il ya quinze ans il fait sa
clé de sa caste affiche est ouvert il a
même vu le mauvais niveau à ce que la
petite dame qui vient nulle trace à la
tue c'est là l'autre joue à l'après fou
rire tous les chiens du quartier qui
sont en effet son jeu lui thomas je lui
demande où il me demande c'est vrai
beyoncé il me demande
il y avait plein de petits jeunes qui
devaient venir aujourd'hui faire à sa
première l'agent de leurs pertes c'est
viennent pas on ne va pas bien là bas
ben voyons ne faisait pas bien touche
pas on passe le forum plage va le voir à
l'europe et metz qui joue les jeudis
vendredis samedis et les places se
vendent comme des petits pains
[Applaudissements]
merci merci d'avoir été là j'en perds je
t'ai pas avec nous
[Applaudissements]